for months we saw Bitcoin trade in a
tight range unable to surpass the
$32,000 level and now we're seeing
Bitcoin hit fresh highs for the year
surpassing
$44,000 so what's changed well you know
obviously price goes up because there's
more buyers and sellers in the market
and so the question becomes why are
people buying uh Bitcoin and I think
that it's a Confluence of things uh
first of all there's speculation on the
Bitcoin ETF um as we get closer and
closer to these uh kind of early January
dates uh I think are just saying look
there's higher probability that it's
going to get approved and if it gets
approved uh they believe the price is
going to go up so they want to own it
before the approval and you know pretty
self-explanatory uh then if you go and
you look at things in the macro
environment um markets are
forward-looking and so what people are
anticipating is someone uh may say to
themselves okay if we've had this kind
of quantitative tightening we've had
interest rates rise at the fastest rate
in history we've been selling off uh
assets off of the federal reserve's
balance sheet uh that's going to change
at some point right if they continue to
keep the econ e omy tight they're going
to push us into a recession and so uh
when there is a return to quantitative
easing the thought process is that many
assets including Bitcoin will rise very
rapidly and so you don't wait for them
to return to loose monetary policy and
then buy the assets you want to buy it
right before they return um and if you
go and you look you know bill acman has
this bet uh that he thinks interest
rates are going to cut in q1 the market
is pricing in 100% probability of a
interest rate cut by the end of Q2 I
think there's a lot of folks who just
say look I'm not going to wait I'm just
going to go ahead and start buying now
uh and so that's providing some pressure
uh there's a third thing that I think is
pretty interesting um I recently was
talking to somebody uh over at coin fund
David Pacman who leads their investment
team and he showed me a chart that
essentially there's been three major
crypto exchange CEOs who have left or
quit uh or been fired from their role
we've have Arthur Hayes um we have S
bman freed and then we have CZ after
every single one of those the market
rallied pretty aggressively very shortly
after um and the thought process being
that whether it is perceived risk or
actual risk the market enjoys certainty
and so whenever there is some degree of
certainty that's brought into the market
then people will allocate capital and
obviously the price will go up and so
regardless of kind of what the actual
reason for the price going up I don't
think you can point at one thing but
what we do see is that capital is
flowing into the market um when you add
in the fact that 70% of all Bitcoin
circulation hasn't moved in a year a
liquid Market Capital flowing in price
has to go up to accommodate everyone and
I think that it's only getting started
right now so do you think the positive
momentum will continue into 2024 do you
think we'll continue to see this rally
yeah I mean my message right now and and
wife and you know doing so much media is
just to explain to people look bitcoin's
bull market has begun and when you look
at these Market Cycles historically
they've been kind of 4year Market Cycles
in between these Bitcoin
havingsex bull market and then you'll
get about a year year and a half Market
correction and so historically that has
been hundreds of percent up and then you
get about an 80% draw down now the next
bull market and bare Market I don't know
if it's hundreds of percent or tens of
percent I don't know if the draw down is
30% or 80% but definitely it is a very
strong indicator that we now have
bottomed out of the last bare Market the
bull market has begun and the question
now on everyone's mind is how high will
Bitcoin go in this bull market speaking
of the having Bernstein recently put out
a report saying that it expects Bitcoin
miners will outperform the broader
Market going forward thanks in large
part to the Bitcoin having do you see
that happening well right now if we just
look at uh 2023 so year-to date uh the
S&P is up about 19% uh the leading
miners are all up somewhere between 250
and 300% um and so if you look at
bitcoin's performance bitcoin's up about
150 to 160% depending on the day and so
the miners are outperforming uh in many
cases sometimes as much as 2X bitcoin's
price and so you got to ask yourself why
is that happening and we've seen this
debate before the gold Community has
long debated should you buy spot gold or
physical gold or should you be buying
these cash flowing gold mining
businesses now they have different risk
reward profiles um but what we're seeing
when it comes to bitcoin miners is in
2023 they have been the better asset to
have allocated to now the question
becomes will that remain over a long
period of time the beauty of the Bitcoin
Community is many people are not
speculating in the short term they simp
want a simple asset that they can dollar
cost average into over time and hold it
for years if not decades that's much
easier to do with a commodity like
Bitcoin than it is with a cash flowing
business that has a management team
they've got to navigate different Market
Cycles they've got to manage debt Etc
and so it all comes down to what the
risk work earn profile you're looking
for is but so far the miners are
outperforming we've also seen some
demand for altcoins this year for some
altcoins take salana for example its
token soared more than 500 % since
January 1st so what do you think is
happening there I think it's very
similar to uh kind of traditional
financial markets right the further that
you push out on the risk curve uh the
higher the potential reward you've got
to get paid for the risk that you're
taking and so what we've seen with
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies is
the market tends to move uh kind of on a
macro basis and so when Bitcoin goes up
other assets will go up as well um in
Bull markets that tends to mean that uh
many of the altcoins will outperform
Bitcoin uh for short periods of time um
but the question in the upside case is
what is the durability right many of
these assets might outperform for 3
months 6 months even 12 months but many
of them then disappear over the long run
and so Bitcoin has been that thing that
remains resilient um kind of over time
now the opposite is true when it comes
to the draw Downs or the bare markets
right many times Bitcoin will actually
draw down less than these altcoins and
so really all you're seeing is Bitcoin
is serving kind of you know the
equivalent of maybe the S&P serves in
the traditional Market Bitcoin is that
for the crypto market and so these other
assets asss will trade with more
volatility or kind of more severity to
the moves um and so you got to ask
yourself who are you right do you want
to be a Trader are you are you looking
for the highest risk possible or are you
simply looking for a solid return and a
resilient asset that you can buy uh over
time and hold for decades and I think
you know what I the way I've looked at
it is when I talk to people on Wall
Street Bitcoin is the riskiest asset
that they have in their portfolio they
can't believe that they've even
allocated you know some small percent
half a percent 1% 2% when I talk to
people in the crypto World they think of
Bitcoin as the least risky asset in
their portfolio and so I've forever said
that's actually where I want to be I
want to have the asset that the
conservative people think is risky and I
want to have the same asset be what the
risky people think is conservative and
so that middle ground I think is really
where a lot of people end up and we'll
talk more about that topic in a second
but data from S3 Partners shows that
short sellers lost more than six billion
dollars in crypto related Bets with half
of those losses coming from coin base
shorts what does that signal to you
shorting a market that can go asymmetric
very quickly is usually not a good idea
um and if you look at Short Selling
generally across the market right in
traditional Finance there's short
sellers that have been doing this for a
very long time they're either shutting
down their firms they're returning
Capital uh or you have a lot of long
short funds that are saying look we're
just not going to short individual names
anymore there there's just too much
unpredictability too much chaos um and
so it just doesn't make sense from a
risk reward standpoint well that is all
put on steroids in the crypto market
right if you're not willing to short
let's say an S&P 500 company what are
you doing shorting a company that can go
up hundreds of percent coinbase
specifically is up like 330 or 340%
year-to date so if you're willing to
short something that can go up 300 400%
in a given year then you really better
make sure you're right and so what we've
historically seen is just humans are
really bad at Market timing and being
long and something going down at least
you have the ability to kind of hold it
for long enough for the market to come
back if you're short and it goes against
you you can lose a lot of money very
quickly and I think what you're
ultimately seeing is not just in crypto
but across the market of Finance many
people are just saying look shorting is
not worth it and I think crypto is kind
of the the cherry on top that they're
just blowing out these shorts and saying
look understand what the fundamentals
are get long and just be passive and
that's probably going to be a better
strategy speaking on Capitol Hill JP
Morgan's CEO Jamie Diamond said that if
he was in the government he would shut
down crypto what was your reaction to
that Jamie Diamond is uh probably one of
the best bank CEOs in history um he's
built a amazing business I don't think
anyone who understands you know kind of
banking and finance can look at it and
say that Jamie Diamond doesn't know what
he's talking about on this specific
topic though I think that there is um a
little bit of uh what is being said and
then if you look at the actions of the
bank there's uh different actions right
and so um one when you're in these
hearings obviously you're you're
speaking to a certain audience and when
you're speaking to politicians when
you're speaking in front of the national
media uh there are expectations of the
leadership of large Financial
organizations or large Banks and I think
Jamie was probably uh addressing some of
the questions from that perspective but
the bank has a blockchain team you know
they have hundreds of people that are
working there uh they forever have been
building out things like stable coins
Etc um on top of that I think that there
is kind of a tale of two tapes because
you also have large Financial
organizations like black rock where
Larry Fink is going on National
Television he's saying look when people
are buying Bitcoin it's a flight to
Quality and so really I think you got to
ask yourself what's the incent here and
if you were to ask kind of people across
Wall Street who is most likely to lose
market share or lose out something if
these assets and these Technologies
become viable it's the banks right it's
not the asset managers the asset
managers are pretty Nimble they're able
to say okay I can create an ETF for
stocks I can create an ETF for Bitcoin I
just simply switch out the underlying
asset and it's the same ETF rapper I can
raise private funds and allocate capital
and so I can go ahead and adapt to
change much more easily than let's say a
bank where part of my business model is
based on transaction fees or other types
of kind of revenue streams that directly
compete now with this new technology
that appears to be much more
advantageous and so you know look you
can put a lot of weight on the words
that are said in these hearings or you
can put no weight on I tend to not
really pay attention to what any one
person is saying in the hearings I
really just go and look at their
organizations and what are the actions
they're taking and so my guess is that
um it was well received by the audience
he was speaking to uh at the same time
you know there's a lot of people who
went to work today uh at JP Morgan go
work on blockchain technology and so
just understand the difference between
those two things is important you
appeared on cnpc's Squawk Box recently
where you argued that America is going
to be a big winner in the crypto and
Bitcoin race but how does that happen
without a clear regulatory framework for
crypto here in the US well if you ask
Regulators they say there is a clear
framework right they'll tell you hey we
have Securities laws they've been around
for decades and uh your assets need to
fit within the existing Securities laws
now there's a lot of people within the
crypto industry that disagree with that
they want kind of new regulations or or
kind of modifications to the regulations
um and frankly I don't know what's going
to happen but I do know that America we
have the judicial system and people are
going to go in front of Courts of Law
and they're going to argue and The
Regulators are going to argue one thing
crypto uh is going to send kind of the
best they have and they're going to
argue something else and we've already
seen multiple lawsuits and and kind of
court cases where Regulators have
prevailed and then also where Regulators
have kind of been said hey I think
you're overstepping here and so the the
American system is going to kind of work
it out and that's kind of the beauty of
America now in terms of why America is
going to end up being such a beneficiary
I think you can really look at it from
three perspective you can look at it
from the individual investor perspective
you can look at it from an
infrastructure perspective and then you
can look at it from what I'll just
consider kind of an economic perspective
and so the individual investors uh the
White House put out a report about two
years ago that said 14% of all Americans
have either owned or transacted with
cryptocurrencies my guess is the number
is probably a little bit higher than
that um and so you have people who
obviously want this right Bitcoin
specifically is an asset that is very
unique and that it's a Bottoms Up
adoption normally new technologies are
adopted the military creates it
corporations adopt it first and then
individuals get it think cell phones or
computers or the internet bitcoin's been
the exact opposite we have seen
individuals adopt at first then
corporations then financial institutions
and then hopefully at one point nation
states and so Americans specifically
have been a very big beneficiary of that
because it's been the best performing
asset for the last 15 years and so if
you bought it and held it you did well
now when we think of infrastructure
China at one point had more than 50% of
all Bitcoin mining hash rate uh sitting
within their borders they decided to ban
it in uh May of 2021 and those people
unplugged their machines and moved
elsewhere the United States was the big
winner in that uh kind of reallocation
of resources today the United States has
about 35% of all Bitcoin mining uh
within its borders the state of Texas is
about 10% of global hash rate and so
when you go and you look at what's going
on in Texas or in some of these areas uh
there's been the former president of
urot which is the uh local power uh
there in Texas and he says look Bitcoin
mining is now an essential component to
balancing our grid to updating and
modernizing American infrastructure so
when you see that you're like okay not
only is America a leader on the global
stage in terms of Bitcoin mining but
also we are in effect modernizing our
infrastructure and balancing our grids
by using this new technology so
America's winning on that standpoint and
then the third thing is from an economy
standpoint right if you go and you look
take coinbase coinbase is $ 35 billion
company right there's a lot of people
who have been able to go ahead and use
that technology and allocate uh
resources towards cryptocurrency through
coinbase but they've also created
thousands of jobs they've been able to
pay a lot of taxes and that's just one
company and so when you go through the
entire industry and you realize how many
companies have been created how many
jobs have been created how much taxes
have been uh uh paid from these
businesses you realize that one of the
greatest areas of economic growth in
America is coming from this specific
industry you say wait a second if we're
going to go ahead and we're going to win
on the individual level we're going to
win on an infrastructure level we're
going to win on an economic level this
is probably pretty good for us and we
should figure out how to embrace it
rather than push it away because if we
push it away what we'll find is that
there is plenty of demand
internationally and so this is not going
to go away what's going to happen is it
will just be created and adopted and
scaled somewhere else and we'll just be
a loser so embracing it is much much
better than trying to squeeze it out of
the
country now in a post on X this month
you wrote One of the areas that crypto
investors seem to always leave as an
afterthought is the public equities
involved in the crypto market so what's
the argument there for investing in a
crypto focused stock like coinbase as
opposed to investing in the crypto token
itself what do you think will yield
higher returns for investors yeah well
just think of Warren Buffett right if
you go and you talk to Warren Buffett
he'll say hey I don't buy gold I buy you
know maybe gold miners I I don't like
the Commodities themselves I like the
cash flowing businesses um and so I
think it's the same argument some people
agree with him some people vehemently
disagree with him and that's what we're
seeing play out here is the crypto
equities have kind of quietly
outperformed many cases two times or
more right you know if you look at again
bitcoin's price being up 150 160% but
coinbase is up 330 340% if you went back
to January 1st 2023 and you had $1 and
you want to allocate it putting it in
coinbase would have performed better
financially than putting it into Bitcoin
now the question is just because of
outperformed over one year is that
actually the right allocation given
what's going to happen over a decade or
longer that's an individual choice right
it's what is your risk profile what
return profile are you looking for what
are all the different dynamics that
you're underwriting and so ultimately
what I think ends up happening is
there's kind of the The Narrative which
is buy Bitcoin and chill right and just
let the best performing asset of all
time compound over a long period of time
it's a finite asset more capital is
going to flow in the price will go up
given enough time on the other hand
there's people who say look I don't want
just kind of the beta exposure to the
market right I want to be able to have
some sort of outperformance and so
they'll use leverage they'll buy
equities uh they'll do all sorts of
different things but if you take more
risk you better get a higher return and
so in some weird way Bitcoin is this
free market asset that really is just
reteaching financial markets the lessons
that we've learned over decades and
they're doing it with a whole new
generation of people and so just as much
as everyone thinks this is different
it's actually much more similar to the
Past than we realize do you think some
investors would Cho choose to invest in
crypto focused stocks like coinbase
because they're more accustomed to
investing in equities versus crypto
tokens it's still a nent industry a lot
of people don't know a lot about it so
do you think that's a factor there in
the investing argument which one to turn
to I mean if you look at you know the
ETF not being improved a spot Bitcoin
ETF in the United States uh there's a
lot of people who say hey I want
exposure to bitcoin but I can't go by
Bitcoin itself and so I would put money
into a spot Bitcoin ETF but that doesn't
exist yet and so instead I'm going to go
buy micro strategy stock because that
seems to be kind of an ETF equivalent
I'm going to buy some coinbase stock
because that seems to give me some
exposure to the infrastructure of this
fast growing industry uh I'm going to
buy some Bitcoin mining stocks because
that seems to give me also exposure to
infrastructure um that's just the lack
of uh ability to allocate directly to
the commodity now there's other people
to your point who just say look we just
buy stocks right we we we don't buy
Commodities we don't go and get the
underlying and so they're looking at
that specifically what is interesting is
if you go and you look at a lot of the
filings from major hedge funds they've
pretty much sat out this runup of these
crypto equities so even though Bitcoin
is up 150% or so year-to date the crypto
equities are up two times more than that
the smartest hedge funds on Wall Street
have been underweight at best or
completely sitting out what has been
hundreds of percent in an entire sector
and so some of that you know you ask
yourself why is it because they've been
so enamored and kind of the attention
has turned towards artificial
intelligence uh Nvidia and other areas
like that is it because when we saw FTX
kind of go down and and there was a real
wash out and cleansing of the industry
people just got disinterested is it
because they don't believe in the future
and so they maybe think this is just you
know some short-term price appreciation
there's a whole bunch of different
reasons why but to see how great the
performance has been but to see how
underweight the best hedge funds have
been there's a very interesting kind of
development there and if you ask the
Bitcoin Community they say Hey you
missed out but that doesn't mean it's
over right there's likely to be more
appreciation moving forward in a
nutshell what's your outlook for crypto
in 2024 what are you paying attention to
the Bitcoin bull market has begun uh I
think that we are likely to see a number
of catalysts that will draw more capital
in um which ends up kind of increasing
demand at the same time you're going to
get uh the supply shock with the Bitcoin
having uh in the beginning of Q2 of 2024
um and so if we go back we've seen this
Playbook before in 2020 uh I spent an
inornate amount of time going around
television print Twitter podcast YouTube
any platform I possibly could find and
explain it to people like we were
setting up for what I called Rocket Fuel
for Bitcoin and that Rocket Fuel was
really the idea that we were basically
going to print a bunch of money at the
same time that we were cutting rates and
the Bitcoin having was going to happen
and that's exactly what happened they
printed trillions of dollars they
dropped rates to zero we had a having
and we literally went from $88,000 to
$64,000 in under a year and so when you
see that type of appreciation you say
okay well if we're Now setting up for
the exact same situation now we have
pretty high interest rates given kind of
last 10 years or so it's likely we're
going to have to return to loose
monetary policy and print trillions of
dollars in order to avoid a recession
kind of Kickstart and keep the economy
strong and the having is coming again in
the start of
Q2 if they're also then going to layer
on an ETF approval it's like we're going
to get a demand shock Supply shock and
we're likely to see a very rapid
appreciation of price again and it
certainly will be interesting to see
what happens Anthony Pompano founder of
pomp invest thank you very much for
joining us and for that comprehensive
insight into crypto markets absolutely
thanks for having
me